what's up everyone welcome back to the
supper suite at Tiff 2022 for another
interview I have two of the filmmakers
behind North normal here huge
congratulations on your movie thank you
so much double congratulations for you
too because High School is wonderful
we're going to get to both but we got to
start with north of normal here Carly
I'm sorry you're gonna have to do this a
million times during this festival for
anybody out there who does not know what
your movie is about just yet can you
give a brief synopsis for sure
um it's based on a memoir written by C
Sunrise person about her unconventional
childhood living off grid in the
Canadian wilderness with her family and
it's a mother-daughter story about her
relationship with her mom
and how they kind of translated their
relationship from the Wilderness to the
city that takes place in the 70s and 80s
you were very ready for that I have
never been that ready before honestly
I'm very impressed and it's also very
early like semi-latest into the festival
um I was reading your director statement
and it was making me wonder how do you
think the movie would have turned out
differently had you made it before you
became a mother yourself
I think that Michelle would have
probably been a I hate this word but
I'll use it anyway a less likable
character
um I wanted I thought giving her more
empathy empathy for the character was an
interesting way to approach her
character after I became a mother I
wanted to be uncomfortable with how we
feel about her and not just be black and
white whether she's a good mother or a
bad mother and I know there is an answer
but it's a little bit more nuanced just
great success in that respect it makes
it feel like a very full engaging
experience across the board with those
perspectives Amanda oh my I have to say
it again you're having quite the Tiff
2022 right now celebrate and correct me
if I'm wrong this is the first leading
role in a feature film for you that's
correct wow wow okay so jumping into
this is there any particular part of the
process of what it takes to lead a film
that you thought like that's going to be
the most difficult thing for me and did
that turn out to be the most difficult
thing or something else Catch You by
surprise I think just
um
generally leading a film versus leading
this film I could maybe give two
separate answers because I feel like
um
I was one of the younger people on set
and I feel like having people like Carly
and Sarah and Robert who were great
collaborators and people to work with
that I didn't feel like pressure to lead
in any way
um
and
although like you know being a leader
lead of a film is
um a big responsibility
um I I didn't feel
um
and like a ton of pressure especially
from Carly she was so generous and
gentle and attentive and that was my
second job I had ever done and this is
Carly's second film so I felt really
safe with her and I felt like she really
understood me and
yeah I don't know if that answered your
question no it does it does but I can't
believe this is your you just said you
this is your second job ever yeah my
second film my god
um just because I have a feeling people
are going to want to get to know you
more after seeing this and high school I
usually ask this in my collider Ladies
Night series but what is the the movie
the performance or personal experience
that first made you say to yourself I
have to be an actor nothing else
that's a really really good question
um
you know I feel like
when I was really young I grew up in a
really
um creative household
um but none of my family is in the
industry at all but I just remember
being super young and watching films
that I probably shouldn't have been
watching that young and just being like
I want to do this I want to play and I
feel like it was that innocent then and
as I got older I just knew that I wanted
to tell stories that
that I that I felt needed to be told but
also experiences that I knew in my own
life I could never experience so being
able to
put myself
in those
like to bring myself into those
characters and and and go back in time
and and you know like live in the 80s or
whatever like that
that was something that really made me
want to do it like I don't know in a
simple way I need an example now what's
a what's a film that you shouldn't have
been watching at a young age that you
really grew attached to
um
probably like
I mean I watched like Titanic at age six
I watched like
um
um Good Fellas with my dad when I was
like nine like you know like stuff like
that like yeah yeah this is like my I
have an older brother so when my dad and
my brother were
were watching that stuff I would sneak
sneak in and and you know join them but
yeah Carly I'll throw a similar question
your way are there any early films that
influenced you and kind of shaped what
you wanted to be able to do and share
with the world as a Storyteller um yeah
for sure
um
I think Sophia Coppola is The Virgin
Suicides definitely did a number on me I
can't even tell you how many times I
watched that movie over the course of my
life yeah yeah it's just like it's so
visually beautiful and it's such a
feminine film even though it has such a
harsh
Edge to it
um it looks like a perfume ad at times
and I love it and it's it's it's one of
those things that I was like here is Art
and fashion and music
and photography all together and telling
a story and I want to do that too I love
that example so so much so I know you
wrote your first feature but that is not
the case on this film so is there
anything about the experience of
directing someone else's script that I
guess caught you by surprise and maybe
made uh the directing process even more
creatively for freeing than if you had
written the script yourself right um I
was involved with the project from day
one so I was very involved in the
adaptation with Alex our screenwriter
Alexandra Weir so I felt totally
involved and had
like creativity in that part of the
process too so nothing caught me by
surprise liberating no if anything more
pressure but I also really valued the
help I had as someone else like Alex had
so much skill and talent and I got to
lean on her in so many ways so maybe
actually maybe actually then I did have
more confidence being like no Alex is
approved of this this is good let's
let's go for it kind of thing very
strong individual voices involved in
this film but these movies do not get
made without collaboration and speaking
of that Amanda I'll start with you on
this can you share something about Carly
as an actors director that made all the
difference for you on set where it was a
scene that maybe you're shooting that
was super daunting super challenging but
because she gave you the support you
needed you were able to crush it I feel
like the thing that comes to mind
instantly when you say said that was
Carly was so
like
um gentle and I think that something
that I really appreciated from her was
even with all the chaos going going
around on set she
she would come up to you and make sure
you feel comfortable and if she had
notes for you she would come and Whisper
them to you and and if she felt like you
were in the zone she wouldn't expect you
to like look her in the eyes and like
repeat what she said and she was just
very like
she would just like it was almost like
she was just putting her hand on your on
your shoulder and and saying you're
doing great but but also do it
differently no I'm scared no no no but
she was just I really appreciated her
just
like giving notes and just being
very like like one-on-one one-on-one
with us yeah okay I'm flipping it around
now because as we've already established
many wonderful things coming uh your way
right now and there's going to be a lot
of other filmmakers out there who get to
work with Amanda so what was it that you
appreciated about her as a collaborator
on this that you know other filmmakers
out there are going to get to bring to
their projects she's game for absolutely
anything she firstly so prepared one
time I can give you a couple examples
one time
I walked in in the bath like she was in
the bathroom and I went to go check on
her we were about to shoot a scene and
she was very emotional and I thought
something had happened do you remember
that it's like oh no like what happened
on set
but she was just preparing for her big
emotional scene that I wasn't even like
I was it was like two scenes away so I
was not paying attention to that part
yet and that she's just I was always so
prepared for like the biggest emotional
thing or the smallest thing always
always prepared and always game week uh
one time at 3 A.M we were fighting
Sunrise having to get like a really big
moment in the film and
uh the light was creeping in and we
needed true night and something was
going wrong
I had to toss out my shot list and we
didn't have Amanda's Safety Shoes to go
in the water and uh I was like okay we
have to wait for the safety to have to
wait for the safety shoes and a man is
like screw the safety shoes and all I
look at her and she's just like 10 feet
already in the water she's like let's do
it
and I really as an independent filmmaker
I'm not the biggest budget film like
she's a lifesaver oh that's so wonderful
so she just gave us a little insight
into your process a little bit I love
asking this question because there's so
many different ways to approach your
work as an actor out there and you're
working with such an exceptional
Ensemble here can you give me an example
of two uh co-stars you have here who
have total opposite uh approaches to
their work where when you're their scene
partner you know you as their scene
partner are going to get a completely
different acting experience
I found that I mean I don't know I don't
I don't really I don't think I really
was
working opposite I don't think anyone
really did anything
that drastically different that I can
like
decipher but I think um
I think depending on the scene and the
character that they played like James
for instance his Sam is like
such a like nut ball like I think he's
so like
um like he brings a lot of like levels
to his character I and I think that he
was just
he would just like to talk and you know
hang out and all that and I found that
that was totally right and I feel like I
mean working with Sarah we work together
this entire shoot so I saw like
tons of different sides of her but I
feel like one thing that Sarah taught me
too is um
sometimes when you're not feeling
present or grounded
um it's it's sometimes good to you know
like
find the physicality in the room and you
know like feel feel things around
knowing that that these things are real
and you know and and I think that helped
me sometimes so that's what I found I
don't know oh it's so interesting can
you can you give me an example of
something like that where I whether it
can get as specific as like an object in
the room that maybe informed your
performance or what the character was
going through or just maybe something
more General where that helped you out
yeah I think generally just um
because
um
like for instance the
um
what's it called on the snow globe right
it's a snow globe I forgot the word
um things like that that see is so
familiar with
um I just feel like
sometimes I've been on sets and picked
up props and been like this doesn't feel
right holding it in my hand and you have
to just kind of play around with it and
and
see what comes naturally to you and I
feel like
you know getting comfortable and
um
getting to know your surroundings really
well
comes like so you're not like tripping
around or not knowing where things are I
feel like
that was like helpful to
to do I can see how this benefits you
and your craft but as you're describing
that I'm like maybe I should just do
that in life more often so I am not
walking around our sets tripping over
everything they're gonna make me let you
go soon so I want to squeeze in a high
school question we've already talked
about how it's early in your film career
I also believe that is the first major
role you have on a TV series so is there
anything about the difference between
shooting a feature film and a TV series
that caught you by surprise
um
yeah I mean it was interesting
um working on a show
um and I mean I'd never shot anything in
blocks before so that was new that was
something new and then also
um
because on a feature film it's it's
usually just one director on high school
we had we had two directors we had CLIA
who directed the first three episodes
who was magnificent a legend yes and
then we had our amazing director Rebecca
Asher and she directed episode four and
five and then CLIA came back but so it
was interesting to
to experience
um
different
like leaders like on the same show you
know so I found that that's definitely a
difference in TV and film that I found
yeah I'll wrap with a question you're
not going to be able to answer you
probably know where this is going I'm a
massive Orphan Black fan
is there anything you could tease about
the show that will convince fans like me
that oh you're getting the look that
will get more of what we love but evolve
what we love into something that we
didn't know what that we needed before
I don't know if I can say anything it's
all good you you know how to play the
game you answered that question
correctly
congratulations on north of normal
congratulations on high school as well
I'm looking forward to everything you
both do in the future enjoy your Tiff
and to everybody out there keep an eye
out for the film we will see you soon
with more interviews from the supper
Suite